I have shoved my mouth filled with
marshmallows then eaten a spoonful of
cinnamon isn't cinnamon at semen gaming
I have dressed up as a little girl and
work those dance moves I put enough
makeup on my face do I do any drag queen
miss YouTube challenges I've done the
mud but seriously [ __ ] this challenge
mom it's me don't be scared
how's it going as my speak one month ago
I announced that I was gonna do that's
above so below
catacombs challenge and ever sends that
announcement every night when I go to
sleep I think about it and I am so
freaking perfect basically what's gonna
happen is that I'm gonna walk through
this horror scenario like real-life
horror and it's gonna take place in the
catacombs of Paris normally you're
actually not allowed to go there so it's
kind of a cool thing but I read that
this one guy wedded and he got lost and
he never came back
so I'm basically fought to my right
neveress all that matter is that you
need to decide what's gonna scare me
while I'm down there but let's be honest
anything is gonna scare me while I'm
down there so what you can do is go and
check the link in the description and
vote I tweeted out what you bros would
think and I picked out your selections
so you get to decide be nice to me
I hear flowers are really scary but
that's pretty much it I just came back
from Italy I'm excited to keep making
some videos for your breasts as always
thanks for being awesome here's one for
you
quite you want more little breakfast